since the November Marshall policy
report we've seen the first signs that
inflation has turned to the corner
annual Consumer Price inflation has come
down from 11.1 percent in October to
10.5 percent in December
that's below where we thought it would
be in the November report
and we think it will continue to fall
this year and more rapidly in the second
half of the year we have done a lot on
rates already the full effect of that is
still to come through
but it is too soon to declare Victory
just yet inflationary pressures are
still there
and we can see that in the data and we
hear it from our agents
and we need to be absolutely sure that
we really are turning the corner on
inflation
and that's why we've increased bank rate
today